hello everyone uh welcome to five hi
data global 2021 uh
uh i'm conrad uh one of the co-chairs of
the conference and we're super happy to
welcome oliver here to talk to us about
machine learning and health predicting
pregnancy
thank you thank you very much
so
[Music]
i'm going to share my screen
welcome people i'm very happy to be able
to present here
talking to
people from all over the world it's
really exciting and
um i also i'm quite a bit nervous but
yeah so um
i'm going to talk about pre-free
which is a very specific use case
that we are working on right now and the
topic is
we want to predict pregnancy
complications with health with with
machine learning and
yeah
let me start by a short introduction
with a short introduction so my name is
oliver riga i'm born and based in berlin
germany and my origin is mathematics and
astrophysics and i've been working as a
data scientist in the german industry
since 2015
mainly at the wonderful company with the
wonderful name unbelievable machine
company i've been working in the data
science department
as
doing projects for
throughout the whole german industry
often car manufacturers of course since
2019 when my son was born i'm working as
a freelancer and since april 2020 i'm
happy to work as the tech lead for the
project pre-frame
so
what will the content of this talk be
first i will
give you a one-liner about pre-free
and then i will of course
do a deeper dive into the medical case
behind
the problem the the
the disease called preeclampsia
and then i will get technical
[Music]
and
talk about the application about the
structure of the application and the
tools we're using
and
then i will of course
talk more about machine learning
providing hopefully all the details that
are of interest and in the end i will
give a short slide about data protection
because we are dealing with very
sensitive data here of course
so um let's
quickly start with the one-liner what is
machine what is pre-free what is machine
learning
pre-free is a machine learning powered
can clinical decision support and home
monitoring tool
that helps
clinicians to manage pregnancies at risk
for preeclampsia and predicts related
complications okay long sentence a lot
of
special words especially preeclampsia
let's talk about preeclampsia first what
is that what kind of disease so
preeclampsia is a multi-system disorder
in pregnancy that means that it can
affect the whole body
and
it has actually a quite high
incidence worldwide two to five
pregnancies per year worldwide
are affected by it and it's the leading
cause for maternal morbidity and
mortality
and to
give some shocking numbers
um we are talking about
10 million cases per year 500 000 babies
lost per year and
76 album maternal deaths
so okay what what is preeclampsia
preeclampsia
the main characteristic is that
the symptoms are very unspecific that
means
that the women
show symptoms that can be caused by many
other reasons so they can present they
present with headaches with weight gains
with elevated blood pressure with
protein in the urine
and
on the other hand on the other side
preclusive can lead to very severe
complications
they the women can have
brain hemorrhage the kidneys can fail
the there can be an early birth of the
baby the livers can be take heavily it
can take heavy damage and there can also
be eclamptic seizures for the women
all things that put a high risk on the
mother self and the baby's health
and that there is a gold standard for
diagnosing preeclampsia it's but it's
just based on
blood pressure and protein levels in the
urine
and it provides only predictive positive
predictive value of 20 percent that
means
to detect to or to to to predict these
complications
we call that we call adverse outcomes
that means that
one of five
four or five women that have the
diagnosed preeclampsia by this gold
standard don't actually develop these
adverse outcomes
um and this is where actually and this
actually leads to the following
situation whenever a woman presents at
the hospital
showing signs and symptoms of
preeclampsia
the doctor has to
gather all the data all the information
about their symptoms or has to take
blood he has to measure her vital signs
get as much information and pos as
possible and then from this
information and also very important from
his own experience with cases he has to
decide whether to
keep the woman in the hospital
or
because he is afraid or he it could be
that there is an adverse outcome on the
horizon a complication
or to send her home
and
because of the um
because
this is a very difficult decision
this leads to
many women staying at the hospital for
um
no i wouldn't say no reason but it turns
out after the delivery that
yeah 80 of them
would have not have had to be in the
hospital
and this is a stressful situation user
research confirms that
pregnant women it's not it's not um
yeah easily said it's not nice for
pregnant women to stay in the hospital
also for a long time
and and they would mostly have prepared
to stay at home
and
also
the uncertainty
knowing that there is the risk for
something but not to know if it's going
to happen
is a big stress factor for the women
and of course also the clinician would
love to be able to to be able to better
predict if there is an adverse outcome
on the horizon or not
so and this is where um
prefix comes into place um we are
we are
training a machine learning model that
helps the clinician
to
stratify the risk for adverse outcomes
and we are also
giving the women when they go home an
app
where they can
at home measure their blood pressure and
other symptoms and other vital signs and
symptoms which are then in real time
transferred to the system pre-free and
presented to the clinician so and the
situation before
was that the clinician if he sends the
woman home
he tells them to come back in two weeks
and pre and in the meantime
every day measure the blood pressure and
on a sheet of paper and then bring it
back
in in the next visit so
that we are very
already improving this situation
um
okay let's get technically
technical
um
so
the preview application
is built up in the following way the
front ends
are the physician front end
and a mobile app for
with the women
the front end and the biggest part of
the backend application are built with
jungle our database is a postgresql
database and for the
mobile apps we have been using react
native
and we've been we are very happy that we
have a ios android
and a web app version so we are
confident that most of the women that
have a smartphone can use pre-pre
our models
serving app is we are only using
scikit-learn models and we are serving
them with with fast api and
containerizing the application to serve
these models with docker
yeah the whole system is running in a
clinical data center i think i forgot to
say that this is a shiny tee project
that's at the biggest clinic in berlin
and um
and this
and the whole system is run running in
the clinical data center and we have a
test and production environment the
whole system was built by an external
service provider so
this is very
this is built in a robust secure and
professional way which i'm very happy
about
so let's give a short glimpse into the
physician front end so here's the place
where all the
um
data from the women is gathered
so
the medical the the mobile app
measurements as well as the clinicial
clinical measurements
and they are displayed to the doctor so
he in an interactive way
um we are not yet presenting um
any
um
any model predictions because we
um are planning to do a multi-center
study at the next step
where we don't want to see the the um
doctors the predictions because we want
to evaluate our models we want to see
how well they generalize and the whole
front end here of course i said it's a
built-in django and this visualization
here is built in blockley.js
um the mobile application
just a short glimpse here
there the women can put in their blood
pressure they can put in
the protein levels in the urine and they
also
can
put in symptoms it's as i said build and
react native
and yeah so let's get to the machine
learning part um
first important thing data
so
what we're dealing with is what the
medici medical world calls real world
data which means nothing else that it's
not data that was collected during the
prospective study prospective study is a
very very
um
highly regularized way to collect data
this our data in the in
is collected
from the clinical systems and it's the
the data that um was produced during the
clinical all-day work from mid 2010
until the mid of 2019 and the bars the
height of the bars indicates the number
of patients per month that are included
in our data set
um let me just mention the way this data
was extracted was that actually people
sat in front of the clinical software
systems and transcribed manually all the
data points into an excel sheet
that's
2021.
um
okay what do we have um
in a specific data point we have of
course for from the women we have their
medical history data the analysis data
age hate body mass index
gravity is the number of pregnancies the
woman had parity the number of birth
she had and many more and also we have
the
measurements from the wizard like
blood pressure at the visit or the
protein measurements or
important blood markers and we of course
have the outcome data data of delivery
details about the baby and of course
our important labels was there an
adverse outcome which one which adverse
outcome was there
yeah and of course multiple visits are
possible
um
these
all these informations all these
features sum up to more than 60
features in total so
our first one of our first task was to
select a sub set of relevant features so
as a preparation for this project
the medical staff just collected
everything that they had about the
patient and our task then was to filter
out the relevant information for
predicting adverse outcomes and that's
the next slide to just state okay what
was our goal for the modeling the goal
was of course to
to quantify the risk for an endless
outcome
in the next x days in a certain time
frame and our labels we had for that
was
labels provided by the medical staff if
there was an adverse outcome after the
delivery present or not and which one
and the date of delivery because many of
the ad or the all of the address
outcomes are closely related to the date
of the loop
so our modeling workflow was like this
we did a 1910 percent train test split
putting test side and then focusing on
the 90 training set
um
with the cross validation
because the data set is comparatively
small to machine learning standards we
did we iteratively did experiments
tracked with emerald flow to do feature
selection feature engineering model
selection
we only used scikit-learn also for um
regulatory reasons because psychic learn
is the most established machine learning
package and
probably the best
i okay i don't want to
it's
it's just for us it's very important to
um
to use packages that we can trust on so
and don't not to use too many packages
because
um and developing a medical product
means a lot of documentation
and yeah
just a short x course and
so and then and finally we of course if
necessary
um
we did a hyper parameter tuning and we
evaluated on the 10 percent test set
um
so let's get into details about the
steps in between
in our experiments
feature selection as i said we had more
than 60 features to choose of and
the easiest first step was to visually
inspect distribution distributions we
looked at
the group by our interest by the target
we were interested in and
looked at the distributions of the
feature
we also calculated feature importances
or we looked at feature importances from
tree based methods
and um we are we used the we use shapely
values
uh here this is a plot from the packed
shep uh
collected
shapely values of every feature for all
samples this is an example plot from the
package i'm sorry because i can't share
actually um
a plot from us because it's currently in
a paper under review
um shep is a
package that i like a lot i highly
recommend i think yeah it's great so
what we also did was recursive feature
elimination
um using sklearn methods and we of
course also did the classical
correlation analysis calculating pearson
correlation coefficients and
we also had a lot of a lot of
discussions with the clinical personnel
and
with collaborating statistics
statisticians about the
final selection of features that we are
using
then
our
missing value handling was quite simple
we
dropped all rows with less than 50
values present and then we grouped by
gestation week and imputed the median
we imputed the median because some black
markers have massive scales
and the gestation week is basically a
measurement
or yeah it's and a pregnancy has 40
weeks
and
each week is
a station week and and you numerous them
from 1 to 40.
another very interesting from my
perspective approach
for in
in terms of feature engineering was the
integration of deviations from norm
values and then so
for some features we had there is um
there are so called reference ranges out
there in the rece in the medical
research
so
meaning
distributions over the gestation week
and over this specific
feature
that um
that tell you what the normal
development of this value throughout the
pregnancy is
and we were we could we then used these
reference ranges and calculated
deviations of our measurements from
these normal values so that
so we presented um we presented our
models kind of
values
um
we presented them features how
how are we deviating from a normal
pregnancy are just to be more precise
from a pregnancy without preeclampsia
another
um another
picture that might make this clearer is
so this is uh the x-axis is the weeks of
gestation the y-axis is the the scale of
the
this feature that i'm looking at it's a
important block marker
and
the gray dots are the measurements from
the study which derived the norm ranges
and um the lines are modeling the
distributions
uh through overall gestation weeks so we
see
this marker is heavily changing
throughout the pregnancy
and so if the blue dot was one of our
measurements from our data of this these
two blocks the stationary 30 and
gestation 35 we would then
calculate as a feature the deviation
from the median for example
we based on these normals we
calculated a lot of different features
um
also very very common in medicine are
multiple of medians and similar things
these deviations for medium actually
proved quite useful and are
in our final model
um
model selection so throughout the
experimentation phase we trained
logistic regression random forest and
grain boosting classifier
we looked into in our first exploration
before this phase we also looked into
other models but like um product machine
and
very simple neural networks to model
interactions but
um
it was
clear very it was yeah very fast was
clear that
um
we are constricted by the
size of our data
very interesting in regards to model
selection the logistic regression was
always almost always on par with
gradient boosting and random forest in
terms of performance
and we were very happy about this
because there is still
um there is still a high skepticism in
the medical world about complex models
that are not easily explainable
and
um on the other hand they all know uh
any any medical stuff that does research
knows a logistic regression and it's
they would
not trust more logistic regression than
a handcrafted neural network or even a
gradient boosting classifier so
we are keeping that aside if these
blackboard concerns arrives arise and
the random forest was interestingly
regularly overfitting on our data
for our hyperparameter tuning we used
hyper opt a very nice package that i
would highly recommend
yes and
i think i have to speed up a bit and our
resulting model performances were up to
90 percent roc aoc
and
on our test set
and to
estimate our
generalization performance or our
variance of
our possible generalization performance
we did the following
after our modeling phase was
finished we
we let the random seed lose
so to say
so we actually
evaluated our models
with
a multitude of 90 10
test split train test splits and then we
measured the the scores on the test sets
and printed them here and so
these this box plot on the very left
side
shows that one of our models had a great
a
high variance
depending on how we did the train test
split this was um
we were not happy to see this of course
but
now i can say that
we um
we got another data set for evaluation
from a very different kind from another
con
continent and a very different
population
and all the models that
were trained on all the different 90
training sets
all
even evaluated
very very
strong and very good on this external
data set so we are thinking
we think that
through the manual transcription of the
clinical systems into the excel sheet
there was a lot of noise introduced
maybe there's there was also before a
lot of noise in our in our labels this
is um
clint so as the clinicians or the
medical world says real world data
but yeah seeing that we are so that we
are well performing on an external data
set
that was actually gathered from a
prospective study was very very nice and
relieving so what our next steps in
terms of modeling
um we are planning to do a probability
calibration and for that we are
extracting additional data from
our center at the charity from 2020
and we are also
i said before we are planning to do a
multi-center study in germany where we
evaluate our models on different
centers throughout
the country
and we're talking to
many different
centers throughout the world
if they would give us their data to
evaluate um our models
yes how did we deploy our models um
straightforward we only have psychic
learn models we pickled them
we serve them with fast api and we
containerize them with docker
the data protection side
a very important topic it's medical data
so we have to be very sensitive and
careful about that
so
during the modeling we only used only
pseudonymized data no names etc were in
there
we
transferred the data between the team
only encrypted
and
the data is also only saved on encrypted
hard drives
and of course we are all very sensitive
about this type of data and very very
careful and how how we
use how they how even how we how we work
with our laptops
in the all day
um
yeah
making sure that it's always locked when
we are not sitting in front of the
laptop and so we have to be very careful
there and the system itself is hosted
hosted on site
at the sharing tea at the clinical data
center so they are taking care for data
security in the same way they are also
doing taking care for all the other
medical data they are hosting
and
as i said all our complete system is
was delivered by a professional service
supplier with a high focus on security
there is nothing
so to say hacked together yeah and we
are also planning a security review
through an external auditing company for
early 2020.
yeah so i'm actually at the end of my
talk i'm happy that i made it within the
time
and um would be great if there are other
teams interested in what we do or
maybe working on the same problem or sim
also decision support system or are just
interested in our case and like to talk
to me i will be available on slack and
happy to answer any question and
of course there are also some open
challenges and questions we are have to
we have to deal with we are we still
want to improve our missing value
amputation we want to know and learn how
we can detect and handle out of domain
data
and so
we also want to reduce the data input
time for clinicians
and are very worried about data sealers
at the hospital that don't allow
connections to them that's an issue so
thank you very much for your attention
and yeah looking forward to talk to you
all thank you
you